you're not six plus don't swipe right or
whatever i can swipe wherever i want
there you go there you go g
why are you snickering like that man
ladies and gentlemen gentlemen gentlemen
uh what song is that
sierra sarah and what's his name um
what's the producer called um
what's his name uh the one that looks
like e40 but isn't he fully
yeah ladies and gentlemen tournament
sarah's actually not piff especially
back then
she she had she had sex appeal
but she was very good at um wearing male
and female outfits
yeah she was like what was that like a
boy
she went home she did go have me there
she did go harder
to be fair i take it back yeah she's
buffing that track she knows how she did
yeah she did the technique she's she's
nice and um
what's the one with ludicrous
um i don't know what song is that
um is it o or it could be it could be
like a boys i can't remember she's got a
track with ludicrous when she switches
up
oh okay um like male to female swag as
well fair play
come on the track is called though do
you remember rudolph the luda chris
first cut his hair
and had the most bomb fade of all time
when he went from
uh like commerce to to the height of
fade
i want to say yes because i'm sure it
was during like
the transition of like fast one and like
two or something level two something
ridiculous and i think after he did it
he was in every barber shop
something like that yeah yeah yeah yeah
he said every barber shop yeah
yeah yeah i want number 17. yeah i want
to be like ludacris
the fade was the favorite he had the the
the little things here uh
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's exactly it
yeah he did yeah yeah that was
banging that's before everyone knew that
this this spriting was a thing
this break the spray filler no one knew
about it everyone thought
why is his hairline so strong his hair
is crisp
yeah every time every time bro because
barbara
needs a raise yeah true i need one of
those celebrity barbers bro so do i
i need one of those i need someone to
pack me up week in week out i just want
to sit there
and then boom bro yeah i literally need
it in my schedule like thursday's at two
this is this is where i'm at yeah if you
want to find me on with the barber at
thursdays at two
and he brings the same heat every week
every week the same every week i need
like kevin hart's barber yeah man with
the gloves and everything he
just travels with him everywhere yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah expensive barber
bro that's expensive it's true the thing
is as well first of all his barber's
banging
is his cuts are the sick yeah he's
coming um
his dreams are nice whether he's done
like though even from one all over
to the fade to everything it's been live
always
but like you know when you hear that
documentary and stuff
[Music]
do you not think like um
i don't know i got this feeling like
because
he said like my brother's probably like
the highest paid barber in the world and
stuff like that like i treat my family
good stuff like that yeah
it's like that's not good
position to be in he relies on you bro
yeah we mean he's the richest barbarian
in the world
all because of you yeah until you decide
you don't want cuts from him anymore
or assuming he's sorry he's cut you off
i'm assuming he
cuts loads of other people my assumption
why is that your assumption considering
he travels with kevin everywhere he goes
i think he cuts the mandem and that's it
i think he comes more than amanda
i think maybe when he's like back home
home
he's cutting people maybe he's got like
a shop or something
i don't feel like he does bro i i feel
like i can't i can't see him kept raking
in all that pee
and not like putting it somewhere else i
feel like he's got a shop somewhere
that he doesn't go to that he owns
you know i mean maybe that's that's the
only way i can see him like invest in
this piece to get make more money back
because i like him i am sure as well he
does travel with kevin
yeah he definitely travels with kevin
and like he's part of their little
group like he gets it when everyone gets
a car he gets a car as well yeah
yeah so like i'm hoping maybe even maybe
even if he doesn't have a shop
maybe even invest in other stuff maybe
he's got like a decent crypto portfolio
i don't [ __ ] know
but i just hope yeah he's not solely
reliant on
on kevin i hope not because that's not
smart business same with all of them
really
yeah i know his trainer's got his stuff
going on uh he's got his own brand and
stuff like that as well see that's good
um i'll never forget that beef they had
them on that lane
i would never forget that yeah it was it
was he he was heated but kevin was a man
he was a man enough to be like it was my
fault i apologize
100 let's crack on yeah yeah yeah i'm
sorry
you didn't even let it last like a day
or whatever you just yeah but it was
that was a heated argument bro
you're not nothing without me or
something like that said do you even
have a house
do you even have a house i found that
very surprising from him
bro very surprising man said oh sorry
it's just all this stuff of having my
boy betrayed me
yeah but i was like still yeah
as much i forgot i could i would i
should that issue
before i would have rocked his jaw one
million percent
yeah yeah yeah one million percent what
a rocket draw
would you have contemplated your
position in like the
in the click um
what if what like consequently yeah yeah
uh like what think well before i rocked
it yeah of course obviously oh sorry
before i
i felt like this then i could [ __ ] up
everything for everyone um
not necessarily for everyone more for
yourself yeah more for myself i mean so
yeah like with my relationships with
everyone else here
yeah yeah um maybe but
it would have been more of a i i would
have rocked his jaw
with the knowledge that we're still
going to be boys again tomorrow
he just needs to learn this lesson
quickly okay okay i hear that you know
what i mean yeah because he was in the
wrong
yeah he needs to learn like this can't
run
yeah even though you pay some bills yeah
yeah all this money
that you're that all this ammo that
you're using for this argument which is
obviously your wealth and all this stuff
and
how you put so much money in my pocket
with this one open hand smack
across your jaw you're going to realize
it means nothing because you're still
5'4
and i'm [ __ ] jacked this open hand
smack
bro when this open hand
claps your face you ever you're gonna
you're gonna fall back to earth like
that
get slapped i'd rather get punched slap
i would rather get punched so that's
such a disrespect bro it's such a
disrespect bro
there's a um there
is a
jiu jitsu uh player called
gordon ryan right he's like the best
jiu-jitsu like brazilian jiu-jitsu guy
like in the world
potentially of all time he's like early
20s
and he cannot be beaten okay people lost
huh he's never lost he's lost years ago
okay but probably in the last i don't
even know how many years maybe in the
last three years he hasn't lost maybe
oh wow yeah he's never lost to the point
where people just refuse to fight him
now
oh wow he just can't lose he's too good
oh wow but there's um
he's the biggest internet troll of all
time he talks smack
jake paul kind of thing yeah he talks
smack bro but not as bad as jake paul
because he only talks facts
okay so he'll only talk about your
fighting record to you yeah like he will
never just
make up [ __ ] and say your wife's ugly
and stuff like that he'll keep it
he'll keep it jitsu yeah yeah yeah and
he'll spit
facts and that's his smack talk okay but
he goes hard
um but anyway he was b for one guy
one more tell like one guy tried to beat
him another guy uh
a guy called andre galvao android
governor is like a
well-respected well-renowned world
champion like
wham guy why i'm short but wham
[Music]
so there's this like um this video that
leaked a few months ago where they were
at a competition and
um they'd been smack talking to each
other and then in person
gordon was like to me it's all online
in person i'm just trying to build hype
yeah in person i'm cool with you bro
like so he went to shake andre's hand
andre gave him the finger
so he was like i bet so backstage or
whatever he must have said something to
him
and andre was following him into
backstage pushed him
pushed uh gordon and said what is it
andre didn't know what he'd actually
just walked into bro
because gordon turned around said yeah
open
hand bro smacked him in his face
and said what is it then
considering i realized considering i've
been in like a few fights
yeah i know how andre felt in that
moment yeah
when you realize oh it's really really
real yeah oh it's
really real and i'm not actually about
it i thought i was
until my brain just shook in my head
and i realized oh this is dangerous open
palm smack
just smacked him you could hear it like
no it's a vile bro
disrespect man said what is it andre
was was stuttering man said
just trying to keep the face there but
yeah he was he didn't know what it was
fight or flight
he didn't know what was what was going
on yeah and then to mug it more
give it four or five seconds of gordon
like
big one if you're gonna push me do
something do something
do something and then gordon was like
please big man please i'm begging you do
something
two second pause do something do
something again
second smack bang do something he's been
smacking
across the cheek twice in 60 seconds
amanda did nothing
his hands were just shaking he didn't
know what was that my man's a serious
guy as well
there's andre galvalga serious brett
when but when real real happened he
didn't know what to do
he didn't know what to do everyone
thinks they've got a bad car until
another bad car pulls up bro
everyone thinks they know how to fight
until they until they taste
real danger yeah until he tasted the
blood on his tongue
he just thought nah he's he tasted like
hemoglobin for this yeah yeah
yeah and there's got law around this is
real yeah this is right
it's not worth it it's not worth
patrolling for the next three months
the violation you smacked across your
face twice why
they do nothing i couldn't ever have
that
but yeah to bring back to the point this
is exactly what i would have done to
kevin if i was a trainer
man said if you've got a house if you've
got a house i would've just while he's
still speaking
smacked him across his face and let him
realize that
there's nothing he can do and then i
would have said nothing i'll just stare
at him
you know in uh the thing i played the
video you know the um
samuel jackson in django when he's on
the porch he's just yeah yeah
yeah that's what i would have given him
i would have smacked him i just stared
at him
and he would have been he wouldn't know
what's going on and he would have tried
to continue
and as soon as the next word if the next
word out of his mouth wasn't sorry
as soon as it's like nah smack again
and i would have educated him there your
money doesn't mean
[ __ ] the cameraman would have been
startled
these netflix stones wouldn't know
what's going on they would know where to
focus
this isn't on script bro i would have
smacked him twice said sit the [ __ ] down
oh my god sit down and every time he
refuses i'll smack him across his cheek
again
and says you need to learn bro this is
the jungle he would
find a way to kill you on that plane i
promise you
i promise you he would have sprinted
into the cockpit and just said down
[Laughter]
[Music]
what the [ __ ] did this he would have
killed
everyone everyone he can't go back to
his misses like that yeah you can't
ah that's embarrassing but yeah
certain man need to realize that money
doesn't mean any everything bro
oh god when you're in these streets you
can talk money money money to the cows
come home but want to smack you across
your face
where is it what is it really really
really what is it
never never come to me about have you
got a house you have to expect a slap
yeah
yeah that's that's disrespect and ego
oh hundred percent bro oh man i hope
i hope one and none no i can't get my
words i hope that nobody i know ever
gets like that
you know oh sorry it would be it would
just be like such a
what's the word such a disappointment
like for them to be
to grow up being the normal person they
are be humble blah blah and then to
get that disrespectful to your boy or to
your friend or to your close person yeah
just like
nah man bro to be fair that documentary
was an eye opener for me
because like i've always had it in my
dreams that i just want to take care of
everyone
yeah so when i'm rich i've always
thought like oh i'll hire my man i'll
hire my manager i'll pay them way more
than they need yeah and i'll take care
of everyone yeah but then that means
you're their boss it
has disadvantages bro yeah it will 100
in some way shape or form [ __ ] up the
friendship
of course i would never hire my friends
for anything yeah i've realized now that
it's probably a very bad idea it is a
very bad you can't mix like friends
yeah because what happens when i have to
sack you yeah we can't be boys anymore
yeah
clearly because you're vex yeah you're
making 100 grand a year doing [ __ ] all
[ __ ] so it's it's a tough one man like
yeah
it's not good but then i would still
want to do it
kind of i would definitely hire my
brother okay
yeah to be like as what yep
away from like anything personal like
probably like a like a business manager
yeah not not business manager but like a
like a financial advisor i feel like
you're because i know your brother
i can tell that he wouldn't or you guys
wouldn't get entwined like that in any
way
with beef because he'll be so far
removed from everything oh 100 percent i
can already tell that
yeah like i would want my brother to
like manage my money yeah yeah yeah yeah
and that's just that yeah yeah and even
if he [ __ ] [ __ ] it yeah and lost me
like half a meal
like i understand his intentions were
good yeah and he's like a
very analytic guy he's not a gambler
yeah so he's not going to be taking
risks with my money
so if he manages to [ __ ] it then it's
like you tried your best yeah
like it is what it is i wouldn't and if
he hits the jackpot one of these yeah
then we all drink we all eat yeah
it's live so yeah the bar from that yeah
bro that that friendship hiring is
sticky sich yeah because i couldn't have
a man talking to me like that
if i worked for like i don't know jay or
something like that mike could never
come to me like have you got a house
have you got a house i pay you i know
you're in glass
almost it's a fight this is
disrespectful
it's too much there's too much
disrespect yeah you can't speak to
people like that right i can't
regardless if you know them or not you
can't man or if
they're friends or not you can't yeah
she's not the one that's the thing as
well because even with the
kevin harting like that's what upset me
about it
obviously i still rate him as a person
or whatever or what what
i'm allowed to see of him but like
there's certain things that come out of
certain people's mouths and after a
point it doesn't matter if you apologize
to me
because that's what's in your head yeah
you've won you just got drunk and said
it yeah you've wanted to say this for a
minute yeah
it came off your tongue quick yeah yeah
yeah you've been realizing this
why has my house got to do with this we
weren't even talking about that
so you've been thinking about it yeah
stop waiting for science yeah so even if
you apologize i would have to blow why
is that on your head
he's probably got something for everyone
just in case yeah why have you got
bullets ready for every man
because you're insecure of course yeah
yeah yeah that would upset me
if someone said like if i was arguing
with one of you man and you man just
released saturn
that's so far removed from the argument
that we're having but somehow there's a
tether of
specificity yeah there's a connection in
there
and you're like oh i don't even know
what we could be arguing about but yeah
if you just brought something up that's
wholly personal
and i'm like swear yeah you could
apologize to the cows to come home
i'll be like wow swear down that's where
it is
when you're alone at night i know where
your head's going and that's all good
i mean you're alone and i know where
your head's at and that's fine
like you know that's hilarious but yeah
anyway we haven't even
done anything just be talking that's
fine um welcome guys
10 minutes in 15 minutes in wherever we
are um
obviously as usual guys jump on the
patreon enjoy that secure that
um guys get on yeah okay i need to see
subscriptions yeah i need
subscriptions to be rolling bro we're
three weeks into this thing now
and it ain't banging so yeah obviously
guys um
on top of that we've got a wholesome
sponsor for you today yeah man
drum roll please
it's not manscape but jokes it is
guys manscaped you already know what it
is you know the vibes you know the vibes
bro
it's it's the perfect package bro it's
the weed whacker bro
it's that third generation battery
charged
flipping waterproof oh forget it i
always forget anti-nick
technology bro it's everything that you
need
to just be smooth and wholesome yeah man
it's the perfect package for your
husband your father your brother
your nephew your [ __ ] brother-in-law
yeah bro your son when he's coming into
manhood bro
whatever you need bro these men have got
you covered
um as usual guys it is
promo code sng
manscape.com promo code sng
20 off and free shipping come on do your
thing
enjoy that send us um send us some pubes
so we know that you're using it
whatever you need to do bro it's real so
we know it's really real
um but yeah man oh on top of that in
lieu
of our summer merch drop that will be
coming with to you guys shortly
uh we're gonna do a what
30 discount yeah 30 discount
so on all current match guys 30 off
uh for the next two weeks
i'm happy with that yeah yeah yeah we're
just doing it as we go
so guys for the next two weeks percent
off all match all over the
the entire collection guys the entire
collection thirty percent off
um enjoy that [ __ ] and uh yeah man
jump in link's in the description let's
go okay
right guys um ff for today so
in 2018 a heroic dad called brad lewis
saved his youngest son
from a fatal fall off a balcony by
jumping after him and cradling him to
his chest
taking a brunt of the impact lewis
suffered a fractured skull
amongst other injuries but still but has
since made a full recovery
that's what dodie looked like
he fell from a [ __ ] balcony
so how did he save him jumping after him
according to oh okay sorry yeah
wow i'll read more into it i've got more
um more context about it i found it the
other day
so this is obviously
um this was in 2018 um he's an
australian guy
so he um the son oscar was
um the son oscar was playing with his
two friends on the balcony
and yeah they were playing with some
nerf guns and his dad's
at his dad when a few of them went over
the balcony the boy ran to see where
they went
and he began to fall over and lost his
balance and slipped
and then brad the dad charged over and
tried to pull his son back up
but the momentum took them both over as
they fell
brad wrapped him around like a cushion
and then obviously he hit his head on
the floor
and he suffered a concussion a fractured
skull a bruise to the brain
suffered from shock but the good news is
he was discharged from hospital
after saving his son and brad had a
fractured skull and some vertebrae
even in the immediate after fall after
muff of the four sorry he was most
concerned about his son
obviously but yeah he survived wow
i was literally just about to say it
didn't say how high the balcony was oh
okay
literally just about saying it was high
enough to smash his skull apart
[ __ ] me bro yeah mom that is
have you seen that video where there's
like um
crazy like dad saves and stuff yes i
have i have absolutely someone
like babies off about falling off of
they're always about to do something
they just grab them bro
like catch them with their foot crazy
like that yeah heroic dads bro
crazy so shout out brad lewis man that's
um that's
my man that's a hero i hope he has a
good father's day boy
yeah yeah that's why he's mrs master
when he recovered the top was slopped
scratched his chest
he said you're a man you're romanced i
married the right one
yeah bro because yes love um a dad in it
like a wholesome dad
yeah yeah yeah a manly dad i love
bravery
that's basically it you love a man
that's brave
ah bro that's it they've won if they've
got a man that's broken yeah this kid
stuff is dangerous man
they do dangerous [ __ ] i bet boy they
actually do
dangerous [ __ ] mad bro mad
oh oh that's wild do you think he
actually had the time as well like once
he realized like oh we're both going
over
he actually had the time to just do this
it must have been i would have been
doing it yeah it must have been a couple
stories for him to like be okay boom i
need to do this this and this before we
impact
that's serious bravery oh hundred
percent
serious breathing 100 i didn't even care
if he was gonna make it yeah he had his
brain intact like he was like
ready like this is it would assume we're
both dead and i might
i would have just been like this i would
have just been falling
just as soon as it's right for all of us
the the
my assumption is the ledge is either
pretty low
or your son just wanted to try and grab
it by all means necessary because
a balcony shouldn't be that low came to
like the top of
the railings railing yeah the battery
surely can't be that long yeah
for momentum for him to have so much
momentum that he's toppled over
he must be six eight or the bar is very
very very yeah i have no idea what
happened bro they missed out some
details
it's uh man it's that's some scary stuff
but some brave stuff
the boy must have thought this is it
this is me you know
he would have been screaming imagine bro
imagine being the little boy
and you just fell off the thing
screaming your dad's grips you you look
down your dad's just bleeding all over
the gaff
concussed he would have buying snacks
till today he's the guilt he might he
must yeah
yeah 100 100
uh how would you feel if that was your
dad
if i fell off and my dad did that for me
bro
yeah i'll be riddled with girl i don't
think i feel like he'd never forgive me
100 i feel like i'd always have to repay
him but like i'd have to repay him back
every day of my life yeah yeah find a
way to make it right
yeah yeah yeah i wouldn't be able to
look at him look at me
without the thought of it in my head
with this huge scar around his head
i'm like dad man because that's probably
never gonna go them kind of scars they
never go
or they if they do go they take decades
to go because it's
massive yeah there's a footballer called
um alex tellers he plays for united
um i can't remember where he came from
but he's our left back for united
our second left back for united he's got
he had a brain
surgery because i think he had a
concussion due to a collision in a
football game i believe
so he's got two massive scars across his
head here
but he's got like um he's got slick back
and he ties it up here but he shaves the
sides so he shows his scars all the time
just because he wants to show his scars
you know mad but he's had it for time
bro
jesus time yeah like them kind of scars
heroic scars
but it's always a it's a constant
reminder like this [ __ ] is real you know
i could have been gone
this live thing this live thing is it's
easy to mix
it miss bro it's wild i'm not
i don't know boy i like to live i know
you i love to live
i know you do them kind of situations
there like you said in earlier fight or
flight man sometimes you don't even
think it's just instantly boom that's my
childhood anything that's the thing man
but when you think about it reasonably
though the boy could be riddled with
guilt
and then the dad all the dad has to to
to take that guilt away to be fair all
the dad needs to say is that yeah to be
fair should probably just let you die
then you'll be like oh okay yeah that
makes sense
yeah what am i even on about cool
rest up yeah get well soon i'm going
yard
um right i've got a would you rather you
hit me this would rather someone sent
this one in
this is the most this would rival was
made for you
okay it was literally made for you
you're the only one who would even
contemplate that i feel like this would
be a thinker for you
okay cool would you rather
take an inch off your tool
and add it to your height or an inch of
your height and add it to your tall
why me why do you think this you love hi
what you'd give to be taller is
astounding to me i wouldn't take off my
tool that's
that's a no-brainer i don't know you
could have a wham tool i don't know i
ain't seen him but
i know but i still wouldn't take off my
tool fair play
um so take a inch off my tool to make me
tall i'll take an inch off my height to
my tool taller which one would i do
ah you have to pick one i know i know
that's what i'm thinking now
um
i mean i wouldn't get i wouldn't want to
get any shorter so i'd have to take
i have to because i wouldn't want to be
an insurer yeah yeah
yeah yeah but i want to take an inch off
my piece either yeah
inches off the tall an inch is a lot
that's a lot yeah it is a lot
regardless yeah that's that's like a
lynch is not it's not going to be my
[ __ ] size of my leg is it yeah
yeah so i'd have to take
i'd have to take the l and take an inch
off my toe if you're tall yeah i'd have
to take there
because i think an inch off your height
if you're not like six three six four
six two six four is noticeable
oh yeah there's notice what are you five
nine five nine
so you'll be five eight five there's
notice of balls fam
random has anyone ever met
a five eight guy before i'm pretty sure
five eights are made up height
mean think about it little conspiracy
theory think about it
okay when's the last time you ever met
someone and they said i'm five
eight you're either five seven or you're
five nine
i don't think i've ever met anyone
that's five days i actually have met
someone that said they've that
i've obviously never measured them but
they've said they're 5a and he works
on the roof in in where i work really
yeah measuring
measurements the thing is that
i don't think there's a height
significant difference i don't think the
difference in height is significant
from five eight to five nine but i've
overheard him say his height to someone
before just like
in passing and he said he's five eight
but there's a difference between me and
him
but it doesn't look as if he's five he
looks as if he's five seven
oh when he says he's five eight yeah i
reckon he's five seven he's begging it
i think he's realized that no one's five
eight so no one's gonna question him
yeah so yeah i reckon he's five seven
okay
i reckon it's five seven begging five
eight all right say no more
conspiracy theory for you then how tall
is rim five seven five five seven in a
bit yeah five seven what's this guy
when you look at him does he look like
rem site or bigger a little bit taller
oh maybe he is 5 8 then a little bit
taller but then again i'm not seeing ram
in a minute
true so i don't know remember hair these
days as well
yeah so that's why he's five eight yeah
he's basically yeah yeah
fair play gang um
so yeah i'm oh see i'm 5 11.
i'm not willing to be 510 because i'm
looking up
i want to be in the sixth club i'm
looking up the only way he's up
i want to be in the sixth club and to
to not be down to 510 means it's just
impossible now it's
always impossible but it's just
impossible now
no matter what you do no matter what i
can't go from five ten to six
five eleven i'm always gonna be you're
crawling
you're there i'm always going to be
scratching at it yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah with the right kicks and the tippy
toe
i've seen it a few times i've seen the
horizon i've no idea
i've seen it to be in the club i've been
in the six club a couple of times yeah
just by chance but 510
nah plus not to brag yeah my tool can't
handle another inch
i'm just saying you know what i mean i'm
really
really happy with where my tools at yeah
i
just it's just it's just there yeah it's
just there
yeah the the the dimensions are perfect
and then when we're in the car
it's just it's just doing what it needs
to do yeah
this whole the the threading business
when you're just getting into it and
it's in out in out in out and out
is already frustrating enough for me if
it was an inch bigger
bro are we talking in length or width i
think you just throw an
engine and it figures itself out it
figures you know when you've got that
play-doh
and you just put more play-doh together
and then it figures itself out
it's not longer or wider it's just
bigger
it just figures itself out yeah yeah
yeah that's hilarious that's that's what
i'm pretty sure
you just throw a ninja and it does what
it needs to do
so i couldn't yeah i don't think my talk
could handle that yeah that's jokes
that's [ __ ] jokes
yeah to be fair though it could probably
hold it on the on the on the flaccid
side
oh if you added one more if i added an
inch and it's my soft tool would be a
little bit more
chesty yeah i mean you'll have a bit of
time to say yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah i'll be more in the
shower gang
yeah showcase team that could bang
are you willing to take that 510 though
5 10.
but then again let me think of my tool
without an inch
without an inch soft oh
i'll cover that i'll cover that um
what would my life be like if my tool
was one inch smaller
your life it's i don't think it could be
any different purely because
if you're one in install you're one inch
taller if you're one your piece is one
you're smaller your one is tall and
they're not really going to know your in
your pieces smaller until they get to
the piece
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah because they don't see that first
you know they see the hype yeah they see
you first
true and if with that one
i'm seeing the sixth club now exactly
and it doesn't really matter anything's
different things are different when
you're
when you've got privileges i'm in the
sticks club now and you've got the perks
all these if you're not six plus don't
swipe right or whatever
i can swipe wherever i want there you go
there you go g
why are you snickering like that man
thinks he's dead
i can swipe wherever you want
um that being said
being i'm pretty sure because of all
this because of like
how it is these days in terms of like oh
i'm six
like if you're not six foot you're not
nothing or whatever all this stuff
i feel like if you say oh i'm six but if
you happen to be six foot on the dot
yeah if there's not a number after the
six yeah you're a liar
do you know what i mean you're either
five eleven or six one yeah it's like
when you're
um you've got a fake id and everyone's
18th yeah yeah it's just like
come on yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah be
original yeah say nice
initiative yeah who's 20. yeah yeah if
you're six on the dot is you're a liar
yeah it's a bit skeptical
yes in it so yeah maybe i'll just add it
on the tool
maybe i wouldn't know i'm just scared if
i take an inch off my tool then i've
lost everything
i love it where it's at an inch is a lot
bro i mean
i'll take off the tool i take up the
tool join the sixth club
there you go it's not different it's not
just length but it's not just girth it's
just it's a tall it's just a bit extra
meat it's an inch of meat
meat just coming out yeah all right cool
i'll still make it work
and then like i said life's different
now that's different you're up there the
atmosphere i'm in the sixth club yeah
bet you're smelling
different kinds of air up there yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
people are looking up now yeah exactly
up up up up
and when i get wham i look i look even
better i look worse i look
like supposed to be like they swallow
spit when they look at you
basically basically yeah
there was they said man i like [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah gang gang gang all right bet
sold six foot is say no
one's gotta go cool
right guys uh this week we are doing
food and drink quick and easy um i think
you'll breeze through this one actually
uh so one's gotta go these are um
obviously eggs
scrambled sunny side omelette poached
scrambled thumbs up um scrambled
something inside
one's got to go i'm poached omelette
really i'm surprised i tell you what
when i was dieting when i used to die
for shows and stuff like that yeah i see
omelettes all
the time okay and it got to the point
i'd eat them every single day
and it got to the point where it didn't
matter what i did to this omelette i
physically couldn't stomach it anymore
like i added peppers ham chorizo like
more butter less butter more pepper less
salt more every i tried
everything paprika everything bro and
it i just physically would gag i'd eat
them so much i would gag every time
if i have an omelet again in my life
it's too soon really
i can't stand on this anymore and i used
to like them
but bro oh my god the amount of moments
i used to eat
i physically can't handle them anymore
they can go they can go
okay okay okay you've had experiences
with obviously yeah cool
all right say no more coke fanta
sprite tango oh
tango can go really it's a budget
phantom bro really
it's a budget fantastic tango for me i'm
surprised you said that because tango
for me
is a lot more fruitier than fanga fanta
in my eyes the orange fanta and orange
tango
orange orange tango is juicy orange
tango
versus orange fanta probably like in the
uk maybe
you get foreign
that's different it's got zest
yeah yeah fair enough all right i'm
surprisingly a big coke
that one again that was amazing oh you
hate coke yeah but honest to god
you pay that extra 150 sugar tax on a
mcdonald's original coke no ice
it does something to you bro no it's
nice an extra 150.
yeah sugar taxes peak so you know they
do coke zero now
in um so mcdonald's yeah it's always
cake zero coke zero
so if you want that original you have to
pay the extra is it yeah
yeah but there's something about it when
it comes you're like it's worth it
it's worth it bro coke for me is just
it's too
fizzy it's too that's how i feel about
uh sprite yes bright seven [ __ ]
it's just too much them things are too
much for me yeah yeah yeah fair play all
right
chicken beef pork turkey i wasn't going
to say fish
turkey or a face bro
i'm not even gonna explain myself turkey
i don't even know why turkey is a thing
all right should we move on
straight away say no more all right
pizza burgers chinese and caribbean
until last night i would have said i
would have said caribbean can go
really yeah yeah and but every black
person has mex at me for that
but that's who we kidding as far as
takeaways go
it's bottom of the barrel sometimes i
mean it depends on where you
pick it it depends on where you pick
granted
but i've never been
i i to order caribbean
for me personally to order caribbean
takeaway
i have to be in the mood for it yeah
like
i don't know man like how do i explain
it similar to india i don't [ __ ] with
indian either yeah
but like yeah really ordinary i've had
some good indians in my time
um but like caribbean as banging as it
is
is always one of them things where it's
like i would just have i would rather my
dad make this
a lot of the time until last night last
night
every and usually with caribbean every
caribbean has a
[ __ ] element like this shop has good
plantain this shop has [ __ ] plantains
yeah yeah
but even though they're [ __ ] they're
plantain and [ __ ] their jerk chicken's
better whereas this place is [ __ ] jack
chicken yeah
and it's just stressful going to find
the right
yeah it's similar that's actually quite
similar to chinese
i agree i've had some terrible chinese
i've had some [ __ ] awful fantastic
terrible chinese in mind but chinese as
a whole is my favorite takeaway
so it's staying awake um
burgers is just like a staple yeah like
you can just be you don't
when you're stressed about ordering yeah
you can always fall back on a burger and
bla let's just get this because i know
it's gonna be
somewhat all right um
so what is it again chinese and
caribbean pizza
burgers i think i'm going to say pizza
can go okay i've actually fallen out of
love with pizza okay
yeah that just surprised you in it yeah
i left it out of the conversation yeah
but
i wouldn't have known which one you have
picked but i didn't think you picked
these already pizza it was always when
i'm just like
starving okay and i said let's just get
pizza but i'm never like
craving a pizza i never stare at a pizza
like [ __ ] yeah
like this is this is what i needed i've
never ever had a pizza in my life i'm
like this is what i needed
no one else likes pizza express i love
pizza express okay
but it's just not in the takeaway mix
yeah yeah it's just not in the takeaway
yeah yeah um so yeah pizza can go man
domino's a [ __ ] hate i'm good i just
i like the dip
okay but that's about it yeah the garlic
garlic
yeah pizza hot dip is [ __ ] like caramel
garlic one it's trash pizza their wings
suck as well
dominoes have changed up their wings
have they they used to have these spicy
barbecue wings and they were off the
[ __ ] hook
thank you now they just have barbecue
wings it didn't even taste like barbecue
bro okay it just tastes like
just i don't even know just wings it's
just [ __ ]
i need to make you my um hennessy honey
barbecue wings one day
okay i'm here for it i love wingspan i
know you do bro
i could eat wings every day forever so
good act speaking of
tell you who's back who's locked down
the boat the the the board of directors
during lockdown for this company had a a
real powwow
and said we need a renaissance we need
to come back
because we've fallen the [ __ ] off so
we're going to use this closure
to rebrand to do everything better and
to come back fighting
yeah frankie and benny's bro okay
frankie
back on the map okay talk to me bro they
were on
so they've been finessing on justine
okay
so they've started up this is the genius
on justi yeah they've got three or four
separate restaurants
that are all actually frankie and
benny's but they're called different
things
okay so they've got dessert place called
pudo okay
they've got a burger joint called stacks
okay they've got a chicken place called
what's it called roosters or something
like that um
oh what is it called something like that
but they've got chicken joint burger
joint
and dessert joint no and they've got a
wing spot called bone jam
it's all frankie and benny's really it's
all frankie and benny's
damn bro it's lit that's good bio jam
isn't as great as i thought it was gonna
be i'm not gonna lie
okay um i haven't tried puddo the
chicken place was okay
the stacks is legit but if you actually
order from frankie and venison just eat
bro they've come back the wings the
barbecue sauce they've always banged
but the wings were just
bang in the burger i had some crazy
jalapeno burger
off the chain the chips were burning hot
but fresh
well seasoned yeah bro everything was
cooked to perfection yeah and i was like
is this what we're dealing with again
we're frankie and benny okay they're
trying to compete with tgis because
tgi's is slipping
i'm not hard tea dressing oh bro i've
had one too many cold tgis
recently i'm not about it at all i'm not
happy with teaching you guys
okay i don't know you've got the sesame
chicken strips yeah obviously
and that's it okay that's it
i love the sesame chicken strips who
doesn't but they're hanging on to that
with a
thread with the jd yeah they've only
just got the license back to call it jd
sauce because it was called satin nails
it was called secret sauce or some
[ __ ] [ __ ] okay or ultimate glaze
or whatever they were calling it
and it wasn't jd anymore and now they've
only just come back and say it was jd
are you reading reports or something
what's going on
you've got some free time i'm in the
stock exchange
just reading up from my days i just keep
an eye on these
i could tell i can tell i'd like to know
where i'm at with my culinary delights
i can tell you but bro teachers are
slipping and frankie and benny said this
is our time
okay this is our chance i might need to
order from them i've not had pranking
venice in years bro
because they were [ __ ] [ __ ] i
remember i took my family that this is
oh honestly this is probably like six
years ago yeah me and my friend my dad
came down to visit me
my mom my girlfriend at the time um
my brother my dad my little brother and
sister
we all went alex and sofia gang come on
come on come on
we all went to frankie and benny's yeah
bro we didn't get asked for drinks
for like 45 minutes no way
they sat us down and the place was empty
bro
oh and these men were just chatting in
the corner that's poor man
45 minutes for drinks
wow i'm surprised you man didn't leave
oh yeah yeah i'm surprised
to be fair we would chat in a way and
then it got to the point where it was
like
wait yeah what's good what's scared of
yeah because you realize you know when
you chat so long you think
you forget you haven't even ordered yet
yeah and then it was one of the ones we
were all chatting chatting
chatting and i think like my little
sister or something was like i'm hungry
yeah
and i was like oh same and then i
thought i haven't
even ordered my food and then i thought
i haven't even ordered a drink
what's going on yeah and then yeah
atrocious
that's probably the last time i ate in
that restaurant like six years ago
yeah [ __ ] atrocious are you
see i do exactly what you do in terms of
if you had to have a bad experience
somewhere
i'm not wanting to complain i'm not one
to write a review i'm not want to do any
of that
i just want to come back yeah yeah and
that's just it i ain't got if
i can't be bothered to complain about
service
for you to then say okay the next time
you come back you can have a free diss
or freedom i ain't coming back i'm not
coming
you've had and wasted your only chance
why would i come back
so experience this again again to be
hungry again no big man you had your
opportunity
yeah you fumbled it fumbled it it's not
my fault your staff are crap
yeah you know it's not my fault it's not
my fault i'm not coming back
you know i've got time to write a little
thing on trip advisor yeah yeah yeah
yeah we'll report you to your manager
yes
i'm just not coming back yeah bro that's
it that is literally it and i'm not i'm
also not one of them wants to like
spread obviously
this is just in context yeah i won't be
like by the way guys don't go into
frankie
oh yeah i'm not on twitter saying no one
go [ __ ] frankie again i haven't got
time for yeah people are saying that
yeah i just don't go back
yeah yeah if everyone adopted that
mentality uh people will be in
people will be in tip-top shape oh honey
people will be in tip-top shape 100
because oh yeah they need to fix up
sometimes people need to fix up yeah
it needs to be a thing where like legit
just
if they [ __ ] up that bad don't go back
just don't go back and then when all
their tables are empty
they're really they'll fix up they'll
[ __ ] they'll fix up
um yeah they fell off bro
they were [ __ ] shocking and every
time the reason i haven't even thought
or
are they on their way back or something
is because there's a frankie and benny's
right next to the cinema
well actually the frankie and benny's
that was next to
um there's two cinemas that i go to and
there's coincidentally frankie benny's
next to both of them yeah i know which
one yeah one odion and once in a while
yeah
both of the one of the one next to the
cineworld in northampton the one that we
go to i think
we've been there um that frankie benny's
is closed oh is it just dot
done oh so that's a bad sign and
the other one you drive past it there's
never anyone in the car park
the one in the same complex is like
nando's and blah blah blah by that big
massive roundabout is it that one
yes i believe so i think so
big massive round about nando's
i think so anyway i can see like
complexes and i feel like i know which
one oh okay i think i think
yeah you're right there is amanda's
right near that frankie benny's
um but yeah there's literally only like
two cars in there
whenever and um i'm like well it's trash
because [ __ ] no one comes here every
time i drive past there's no one here
so i'm like cool and then ordered it the
other day and i was like
cool these men have had a meeting
they've had a chat because there's
something different going on here
there is something different going on
here and i'm here for it so have you had
this
only the once since this like reopening
oh yeah once
okay so i'm gonna give it a break come
back yeah
before obviously i've spread the word
too early guys wait for me
i'm gonna order it again in a few weeks
give them to some good delay between
see if they can keep this momentum going
and we'll order it again if it bangs
again
i'm gonna tell the world yeah okay say
anymore i'll wait yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
because frankie like i said frankie
bernie's cgi i haven't ordered in years
and
i'm fine without it you know tji need to
have a meet and greet
they need to sort something out bro
because if it wasn't for those
chicken strips yeah they'd be done in
the cup they'd be done at it
what else have they got you're fuddy bro
even their ribs are falling off bro
i hardly get their ribs i hardly ever
use yeah the ribs are falling off their
stakes are falling off
they're [ __ ] if all they've got is
the jd sauce and the chicken strips man
yeah to be fair that's all i want bro
that's what anyone wants because the
rest of the menus [ __ ] [ __ ]
they used to come with these sizzling
fajita plates they don't care about it
anymore
the where's the flavor man
you're heavily infected you're heavily
invested
that's so i used to ride for teachers if
my parents were ever taking me tgis
oh good friday it's my birthday it must
be yeah
[ __ ] sick i loved it and then it used
to be impossible to rock up there and
get a table on yeah
yeah yeah it's always wrapped bro we
used to have to drive all the way down
to london because there wasn't a tgis
when i lived in luton
we just had to drive all the way down to
london to go to see guys you better hope
we've booked ahead because if we haven't
there's a queue out the door
and you have to get their little buzzers
did i go
if it was it first your second do i go
tj's and i got frankie benny's for my
birthday do you remember you and frankie
bennett
when i'm not trying to introduce you to
ribs yes and you i was like they're the
best thing you've ever had
because you've never had yeah but
obviously guys if you had been a muslim
he'd never had pork before
so i was like ribs ribs drips and they
gave you the worst ribs
ever bro and i was so gutted worst thing
ever
i'd hyped these ribs up so bad man i was
so they were so average yeah
and you were like are you serious is
this it
i tried to introduce him to ribs bro and
it came [ __ ]
i was so upset but um i'm glad you had
good ribs now yeah i've had very good
ribs yeah yeah
um but anyway
yeah you used to have to get the like
literally the [ __ ]
they'll buzz up so they can sit you down
and then you rock up there
and then there'll be donnie behind the
bar doing all this yeah and they're like
oh there's not another seat for like an
hour and a half but do you wanna like
wait at the bar
back in the day you'll be like yeah bro
it's tgis i'll wait i'll
wait anywhere you put oh wait yeah i
wear the bar and have a few cocktails
bro yeah this is it
now what do you guys think shitty bro
tjs ain't [ __ ] nowadays oh you sweep me
bro yeah i'm disappointed man they need
to come back i can tell
they need to come back because they've
got the potential yeah
it's one of the last long-standing like
american style restaurants that people
like to go to
they used to have stuff like fatty
arbuckles and that do you ever remember
that
fat it up fatty arbuckles was
legit no fatty arbuckles was sick
it was american dino spot like tjs it
was like a chain
american dining restaurant okay it was
legit i hope someone hits the comments
like yo fatty r buckles
oh these might as well they're
milkshakes garfunkels as well as a spot
now
maybe garfunkel's i'm sure is american
spot um
i'm pretty sure what's the other one
there's another
buddies is one trash
oh really really buddies
is [ __ ] one of my boys took me to our
buddies one time people you saw my
buddies but there's like a buddies
like a few miles away from where i live
yeah back a day
when i was dieting again for a show one
of my other boys who does
uh did bodybuilding as well was like oh
it's my cheat day do you want to go
buddies
yeah and i was like i've heard stories
about this buddy's place take me
bro worst easily in the top three worst
meals i've
ever had why it was just [ __ ] everything
they brought to the table was [ __ ]
[ __ ] you eat in i'll take it away
we ate in yeah too much sauce on the
plate
whatever i ordered i remember was
dripping it like swimming in sauce
grim like just the flavor was awful
like they used gravies and [ __ ] that
shouldn't have gravies i don't know i
can't even remember what it was but i
just remember thinking
this is [ __ ] awful bro
i remember having something barbecued
and didn't even have any smoky tang
nothing it tasted like bitty and like
peppery and just like
horrible [ __ ] horrible and i was like
are you serious and my man was
backing it white don obviously he was
like yeah this is me
this is me he was like this is amazing i
wanted to smack
everything off the table the tray you
don't know flavor big man
i literally like is this a joke you
don't know is this a joke
bro [ __ ] this this is this this is awful
um but anyway what was the question
[Music]
it was chinese career pizza and burgers
and i say pizza yeah
okay we've got one more to go yeah yeah
let's do it
what was the question so last but not
least we've got mac and cheese
spaghetti bolognese carbonara lasagna
mac and cheese spaghetti bunnies
carbonara lasagna
oh man
if you were to ask me this a couple
years ago i would have said carbonara
can
bounce but i've got way into making
carbonaria
ever since i watched master of none and
he made his own carbonara from scratch
i remember thinking i need to get on
this bella makes a
banging carbonaro is it yeah yeah
carbon's live i think spaghetti
bolognese can go yeah it's it's basic in
it it's super
it's very basic compared to the other
things where's the flavor in that
it's just tomato where do you think you
are james
this is a [ __ ] chef channel
oh i feel like i'm on the food network
yeah this obviously your jokes bro
oh okay yeah but in comparison to that
lineup splag bowl is basic
it is basically [ __ ] trash
oh my god just tomorrow that's jokes but
anyway i hope you guys enjoyed that one
that was a good one
um because i thought it was trash when i
was writing it down really yeah when i
was right i was thinking ah
these ones are boring but i like them
ones bro that's good that i like
i like the food ones and i loved that
over 18 one year
that was dope i really really enjoyed
that one um but yeah guys we're going to
sign off on this one
hope you guys have a fantastic week jump
on the patreon jump on the merch
uh 30 off links in the description
and uh yeah man have an amazing day i
love you guys
see you soon peace